تم إنشاؤه كصورة دعائية
لضرب كل الجماهير ، الفرعون
هو إله جميل ومنحوت بشكل
طبيعي منذ حوالي 3000
عام بشكل واضح لأولئك الذين يعرفون
هذه الأشياء ، مات وجه الصبي الملك
توت عنخ آمون عرمان عظام وجنتان عاليتان
ممتلئتان بالشفاه الحسية ولكن كان كريستي على
حق  لبيع هذا التمثال في مزاد ،
هذا يوم أسود لعلم الآثار ،
أعتقد أنه يجب أن يشعروا بالحرج ، أعتقد
أنهم يجب أن يخجلوا ، أنا غاضب
ويجب أن تغضب العالم بأسره ،
يجب أن تغضب لأنه لا توجد
أخلاق هنا.  لم يكن هذا
التمثال ليراه الجميع تحت الأضواء الساطعة
لغرفة البيع في لندن ، حيث
أرادت السلطات المصرية تأجيل المزاد ،
وتقول إنها انتهكت
الاتفاقيات الدولية ، وطالبوا بإثبات أن
التمثال غادر مصر بشكل قانوني ، وطلبوا من
دار المزاد توثيقًا حول
مصدر التماثيل.  ويقولون إنهم
لم يفهموا ذلك
، دحض كريستي هذا ، لذلك نحن
على اتصال بالسلطات الرقمية
في كاليفورنيا  iro وفي السفارة المصرية
هنا وأبلغناهم بالبيع حتى
قبل نشر الكتالوج
ولذا لدينا علاقة تعاونية
معهم وقدمنا لهم جميع ال
علومات التي لدينا على أم
كن القطعة كدور نلعبه في تو
ير  سوق شفافة وشرعية
لن نقدم أبدًا قطعة حيث يكون هناك
أي قلق بشأن مصدر
د.  تعتقد حماس أن التمثال
أزيل بشكل غير قانوني من معبد
الكرنك بالقرب من الأقصر في وقت ما بعد عام 1970
مرة أخرى خلاف كريستي على هذا ، حيث يقولون إن
أبحاثهم تظهر أن القطعة
موجودة في مجموعة أوروبية منذ
الستينيات ، وتم نحت التمثال من
الكوارتزيت البني وليس فقط لأنه
جميل جدا ونادر جدا ولكن الموضوع
بالطبع كان من المشاهير منذ ما يقرب من
قرن من الزمان شوبانكار
مون هو ملك الملوك شكرا لقمرنا فريد من نوعه
أن نشكر قمرنا على اختلاف
أمور توت عنخ آمون لأنه مشهور
سمعنا عنه جميعا  نظرًا لأنه
تم العثور على قبره بشكل فريد في عام 1922 مع بقاء كل
كنوزه الذهبية سليمة ، فإن هذه الكنوز
ستكون عامل الجذب الرئيسي عندما يتم
افتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير الجديد أخيرًا بالقرب من
القاهرة العام المقبل على الرغم من المزاد الذي
يقول المصريون إنهم سيستمرون في
محاولاتهم لاستعادة التمثال نيك.
زجاج سي ان ان في لندن
لك